hey guys this is Evan Carmichael my one
word is believe and I believe that all
the world's major problems will be
solved by entrepreneurs so to help you
on your path today we're going to learn
9 surprising facts about Alibaba founder
Jack Ma fact number one he used to guide
tourists for free in China for nine
years to learn new ways of thinking for
nine years
every morning almost the weather snow
rain Sun I went there looking for
foreign tourists to become the free
guide and I made a lot of friends this
trained me the way of think different
from the other kids in China in my
generation because everything I learned
from the tourists foreign tourists are
so different from the things I learned
from the my from the schools my parents
because we thought China were like that
the world like that in our books you
know but the thing that I learned from
outside there's that's so different so
that trained my way of thinking
different when people talk about
everything when everything people agree
normally I'd take one minute to think
about is that true when everything
disagree as they take about one minute
think about it hmm
is that true so that was a training fact
number two his hero is Forrest Gump the
hero I had and flourish to go a 14 years
ago in a watch eat chocolate
yeah you know it's a fictional character
though like that guy I've been watching
that movie for about 10 times every
summer when I've rested I watch the
movie and I watch movies before I came
here again were you know what for this
before coming to the New York ID because
I what I watch the movie again telling
me that no matter whatever change you I
you and I'm still the guy 15 years ago
you know I only earned like a $20.00
amount and today I can do that much you
know
fact number three he has no technical
background started with one dollar in
his pocket and beer was the first thing
that he searched on the internet and
when I go to register company home
internet registry officer said no
there's no such a worthy to an
additional money register and each net
we have to register under the name is
what it was the names that compute
consulting firm and I have no idea of
what to do so my first company pounds of
hope computer consulting firm it was
tough
without knowing anything I'm enough
technology without knowing anything
about computer past 15 years we working
I call myself like a blind man riding on
the back of the drive titers those
experts very important they all fell we
survived because three more advantage
with relief refuge we change ourselves
we have continuous mom made it into
college on his third try and became an
English teacher with no computing or
engineering background
he's an unlikely tech Titan but he says
he was captivated by the internet from
the moment he first saw it in 1995 when
he came to the US as a translator I
never touched keyboard before I never
using computer before and I say what is
Internet is a jack and I'll search
whatever you want on the Internet how
can I search what is such me is it just
the type I don't want to type
Computers so expensive in China I don't
want to destroy it he said it's not a
bomb
just the type so I tapped the first to
work of beer at that time very slow come
out the American beer Japan beer in the
German beer but new China beers I was
curious and I was type of China no China
no datum came back to Hangzhou with one
dollar in my pocket scared worried and I
came back and I said I want to do
something called internet fax number
four his life is full of failures and
rejections tried to get into three
colleges each time they rejected you
know I tried there's a examination that
young people if you want to go
university of the taste take the
examinations so I flew to three times a
lot of so I feel for funny things that I
food a key primary school tests for two
times and I filled like that three times
for the middle school middle schools and
you will never believe in in Hangzhou my
city there is only one middle school
that lasts only one year it was changed
from primary school middle school
because our graduates of our our Alice
school no universe you know middle
school except us because we were too bad
I will become a little girl when I ended
you from University and before you know
for three years I tried fill-in to
universities so I apply jobs for 30
times got reject it
I went for a police they say no you're
not good I went to you know even the KFC
when KFC came to check up do I say
yes I see 24 people went for the job
23 people accepted I was the only guy
and we went for please five people all
of them accepted I was the only guy deny
respectfully so to me being turned down
rejected oh by the way I told you that I
would apply for Harvard for 10 times
rejected I know you reject our sorry now
ten times you wrote them and said I'd
like to come to Harvard
yeah and then I told myself someday I
should go teach there baby
fact number five he chose the name
Alibaba because he liked the Open Sesame
story why did you call the company on
Bubba I like the spelling and like the
vision Alibaba Open Sesame
I believe the Internet is Open Sesame
and there's a password that to everybody
that you can find a great people you can
find a great opportunities of business
and improve people that that that is
Open Sesame story I love the Ahly book
everybody saves me a lot of marketing
daughters when I started I think
Internet is global we should have a
global name and I named that interesting
like the dead time the best name is
Yahoo right I think I can so I've been
thinking for many days suddenly Alibaba
is a good name so I I was happened to
being sent San Francisco today and I did
have a lunch and the waitress can I ask
you do you know about Alibaba she say
yes I do
what is Alibaba she said Open Sesame
good
so I read on the street ask about 10 to
the people they all know about Alibaba
for TCS and Open Sesame
and I think this is a good name and
start with a whatever you talk about all
the bubbles on the top
fact number 6 he learned English by
watching TV because there were no other
options in China at the time since
there's no way to learn English at that
time there's no teachers in our city who
can teach people to speak English so I
listened to the BBC and Voice of America
and there every evening 9 o'clock 8
o'clock to 9 o'clock I open my video
from the first Monday Wednesday and
Friday I listened to the VOA the first
book I heard about is the adventure of
Tom Sawyer fact number 7 he performs
mass weddings for his employees he has a
curious way of making his employees
happy the mass weddings he does and you
know we were looking at the footage and
we're talking about it as a team and
what it's doing and why is he doing this
uh-huh
at first when I heard about the mass
weddings I thought well that sounds a
bit cultish I don't know of any business
person in the US who marries their
employees I think it's fair to say there
are none really yeah
they should learn they should learn
maybe she'll learn they should make
their employees happy if they want to do
it that's beautiful them the way of work
I believe is that couples get married in
a variety of ceremony then one day a
year they all go to a huge party that
Jack stages at Alibaba headquarters why
we do this 10 years ago because the
Czar's virtually all the employees in
the company was quarantined and I was
locked in the room for 10 days but when
when I left the room I said to myself
life is so shut so beautiful don't be so
serious about a work in the other lives
so tanker is inaudible this year we got
how many 600 700 couples day 9 you know
announcing nice today
your Vince Barrett Dawson Hydra yeah
[Applause]
fact number 8 he wants to retire early
explore other interests and die on a
beach
people say oh this is unscented
versatile world everyday setting the
only certain day was yesterday I'm not
sure about that in the future I think I
would dictate I will be stupid that's
why I should retire early when I'm young
that is why I have a lot of things that
the dream I want to do I'm on those
throughout the day I want to be a
teacher I want to go back to school I
want to do the environment and the world
is so wonderful why should be the see of
all evil all the time I'm coming to this
world not to work I want to come to this
or to enjoy my life I don't want to die
in my office I'm going to die on the
beaches Fox number 9 he once dressed up
and sang the Lion King theme song to his
employees I had worked as a vice
president in his company for nearly 10
years as our team survived the internet
bubble fought a war with eBay and
managed to build China's first global
Internet company I settled into my seat
and wondered how would Jack addresses on
this important night and then just like
any other billionaire in the same
situation Jack took the stage
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
well it may not have been typical for a
company chairman but it wasn't
surprising coming from Jack people
outside the company assumed he was crazy
but those of us inside the company knew
better so thank you guys so much for
watching I hope you enjoyed I'd love to
know what was the most surprising fact
that you learned about Jack Ma in this
video leave in the comments below really
curious to see what you have to say
thank you so much for watching I believe
in you I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one where it
is much love I'll see you soon